last year was teddy bridgewater with joe
brady and carolina brady the offensive
coordinator under matt roll now sam
darnold the guy also that i don't think
i've ever seen
the plexiglass
backdrop for the press conference yeah
you know i noticed that too i feel like
i saw it somewhere else recently
um i like it i do too i like it because
you see it you know you see it a lot
over in europe with the soccer that's
where i feel like i've seen it more than
anything but yeah it's it's a cool look
it really is i mean they could just move
him over a little bit and center it it'd
be perfect but yeah i like it i'm with
you look at look at you look at you with
all the i'm mr tv guy over here
the the the best b-roll of the year
though has been the the bears with the
train rolling by in the background
that's just awesome i think every
football practice should at some point
have a train rolling by that's as old
school as it gets uh sam darnold new
experience for him with the carolina
panthers the look the panthers clearly
in the market for a franchise
quarterback and we even thought that
they would consider taking a guy with
the eighth overall pick because david
tepper the owner of the team determined
to get a guy that's gonna be the guy for
the next 10 or 15 years and with sam
darnold hey you're the guy
but just like teddy bridgewater you
could be the guy for only one year so
you got him at number 19. yeah and he's
in front of some big names he's in front
of a guy that won a couple of super
bowls that's right ben roethlisberger
he's in front of jimmy garoppolo
why do you have darnold based on what
we've seen the last three years
including seeing ghosts on a monday
night against the patriots why do you
have him at 19. well because i think
there's talent there there's real talent
that has not really been exposed quite
yet you know that i think that like what
joe brady's saying right there you know
there's some really high-end things to
like about it now yes it's hard to see
now let's not forget we heard rumors
about teams wanting to trade for sam
darnold 49ers were one of them looks
like they might have been trying to
replace a jimmy garoppolo with a sam
darnold but i think when you assess sam
darnold you got to be fair here you know
what did you really expect you know a
young quarterback going into wait for it
oh the worst situation in the freaking
nfl and as you've heard me say before
when you're around crap and craps all
around you you're gonna start to smell
like crap and get some crap on you too i
don't know okay yeah thank you well that
will be fine well it seems to hit home
when i say it a lot of times because
people go yeah you know what you're
right there's been nothing there to
support him now has his pipe been
perfect no but i think sometimes the the
play that hasn't been perfect is because
of the circumstance once again yeah he's
young but trying to push the envelope
maybe doing a little more than he should
because the team stunk so he feels the
pressure that way
lightning quick release go ahead but
don't you at least chris
at some point in your first three years
in the nfl don't you show us something
of what could be i mean if patrick
mahomes had been drafted by the jets in
2018 third overall okay he would have
seen something in the first three years
to make us say wow this is the guy he is
the one he just has as you would say
crap all around well like
yes all right so first off it's a great
point and question you're asking it's
also let's just not forget we're talking
about patrick mahomes who we're me and
you i think we're both fans to say it
might be the most talented quarterback
we've ever seen in the history of
football
and with all that if he was there yeah
we would go damn it's good whoa it's
exciting it's fun but you know what
instead of two and 14 last year they
would have been four and 12. like it
wouldn't have been that much better as
awesome as mahomes is i mean when you're
throwing to chris hogan who's in you
know a lacrosse league now and braxton
berrios and other people who nobody
knows of are your number one targets
i don't know what people expect and then
you're running back as frank gore
no disrespect to the future hall of
famer but he's 74 years old now okay
they don't have a good offensive line
and the defense wasn't good you know so
yeah it's a tough like eval when you
take that into account mike but like
when i do watch him on film
i see a guy that still has got
a lightning quick release can make every
throw on the football field to me he's a
phenomenal as you've heard me say before
intermediate thrower and
he's a way better athlete than people
give him credit for it that's the other
thing when i went back and watched i
just went damn we got to give a little
more notice i mean the guy went for a
52-yard touchdown against the denver
broncos right up the middle weave
through everybody ask jeff heath how he
feels about sam darling when he ran him
over on the end zone on a quarterback
you know read option play so he can do
that and he's gonna wait wait did you
say ronnie lotter jeffy jeff heath it
doesn't matter yep he's a safety and
that's a quarterback and he got ran over
okay so there's some real athletic
ability he's tough
and
you know
he's got a really unreal ability and i
think we'll see it this year now that
he's got a little more talent and the
field will be more open because there's
more weapons there
this like ability to scramble in the
pocket almost it's almost not it's like
you know how ben roethlisberger used to
be he was like fred flintstone running a
little area well sam darnold not like
he's fred flintstone but he's great at
hopping around and moving and making
people miss that way and able to throw
on the run while like kind of looking at
the rush but looking up field at the
same time so yeah maybe i'm a little
higher than most on sam darnold but oh
you are i am but i think that
i think the circumstances have to be
taken into account here and i think he's
going to open up a lot of eyes this year
in carolina
i'm very disappointed
with the control room
chris sims makes a fred flintstone
reference and he doesn't get
the ragtime piano
really uh no ted flintstone nope because
you're talking about like when fred
flintstone and now i'm gonna get the rag
time for talking about you talking about
when he would bowl
his tippy toe bowling is that what
you're talking about that or just you
know just when he's in the car you know
when he's in the car and his feet just
go like this right like to me that's how
ben bothelsberg used to shuffle his feet
around the you know got it yeah thank
you uh but you're right i guess i'm kind
of dating myself there too with that but
see the problem is kristin who's in the
control room's
you know not that much
younger than me to where she doesn't
want to play that music because she's
like well damn then i'm old so
they're doing a reboot of they're doing
a reboot of the of the flintstones i
think it's like an updated
uh like you know like the kids are grown
up flintstones i think i saw that okay i
could be i i may have just dreamed it
too that's entirely possible but there's
a new animated flintstones that that is
coming um
all right uh which has nothing to do
with what we're otherwise talking about
so you think um
and i think the panthers view this as
an investment a strategic investment
yeah they've got him under contract next
year at 20 million fully guaranteed
because they picked up his option yep i
don't think that means he's necessarily
going to be there the next two years
they owed teddy bridgewater 10 million
guaranteed and they found a way to
offload him i think they are so
determined to get a franchise
quarterback they're willing
to
to roll the dice yeah with darnold right
and see if it works right and if it
doesn't
desean watson russell wilson someone
else they're going to keep turning over
stones until they find their franchise
quarterback and that's what this is last
year was teddy bridgewater nope this
year it's sam darnold they're gonna turn
it over they're gonna see what they have
i will yes maybe no yeah i'll i'll be
shocked all right i'm just i'm gonna put
myself out there i will be shocked if
sam darnold doesn't have a really damn
good year
and earned himself at least another year
or two of being the starter in carolina
i think he's handmade for the offense
too mike you know he's got a lot of that
joe burrow-ness about him and that's
where i see the fit the offense of that
just he can read and react and dissect
and get it out of his hand quick hell
mccaffrey boom dj more boom you know
that's where i get excited and of course
he's got a little connection with robbie
anderson having played with him in the
jets uh already too so
it's the first time that where he's
gonna have talent a good system around
him in his career and it's not gonna be
you know he's not gonna feel the
pressure of having to do too much or do
something like that you know he's and
that's where i think we're we're gonna
see sam darnold not to say he's gonna
justify being a top five pick but i
think he's gonna show everybody that
he's a starting quarterback in the nfl
this year and and maybe silence some of
these haters
gets his old team right out of the gates
week one against the jets and then the
test comes with the saints and look if
if you're right if you're right
the panthers have a chance
to compete with the saints for second
place in the division behind the
buccaneers i i don't want to write off
the scene i don't want to write off the
saints as being 14-3 either because with
sean payton
you put anybody at quarterback and and
this is no disrespect and it's just what
he can do with whoever he has whatever
that play is right he can turn it into
something and he's got a good team
around whoever the quarterback is so
they they could still be very good but
it sounds like the panthers could be
very good as well in your estimate
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports